Hey, David.
Marianne Williamson has ended her presidential
campaign.
How will this affect the democratic primary?
I dunno if this is a joke.
Uh, because her ending her campaign is of
absolutely no consequence.
But let's imagine that it is not a joke.
Marianne Williamson was pulling 0.3%.
She hasn't been in a debate for months.
Her ending her campaign will have absolutely
no effect whatsoever on the primary.
She was never a serious candidate.
I interviewed her years ago.
She seems like a perfectly nice person when
I spoke to her.
She has some wacky pseudoscience ideas.
Her message of love is fine.
We could all use more love and less hate.
That all seems fantastic.
Her campaign struck me as a bit of a book
tour.
I can't think of any cabinet position that
Marianne Williamson would be a good candidate
for.
I think she may actually be the least consequential
candidate who has dropped out of the race
so far.
I want to hear from you if I'm missing something,
if this is a serious question, how will Marianne
ending her candidacy, uh, impact the democratic
primary?
If you think it will have any impact whatsoever?
I do want to hear from you.
I don't see how it will and if it's a joke
of a question, very well done.
It's so subtle that I didn't even notice.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
It's Friday, meaning producer Pat takes the
reins of the bonus show.
I will be back on the bonus show on Monday.
Sign up instantly, instantly.
I'm talking instantly@joinpacman.com reminder
for all of our current and future chess players
in the audience.
Tuesday the 21st we will be having our first
ever David Pakman show chess tournament.
Okay, 8:00 PM Eastern time.
I will live stream my participation in the
tournament starting at about 7:30 PM Eastern
time.
The chess itself starts@eightpmleadchessdotorgiswherewewillbedoingthetournamentallychess.org
it's free.
Everything here is totally free.
It doesn't matter whether you play chess or
not.
Everybody's welcome.
The system will manage the tournament.
It'll start matching the better players against
each other.
It all will work beautifully.
It's going to be a great time.
We're building community at the David Pakman
show.
I'm inviting you to participate
Tuesday, February 21st 8:00 PM Eastern time
in the first ever David Pakman show chess
tournament.
More about that on Monday, off to the bonus
show for our members and Patriot, the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].